you somehow figured out how to stay in
america well so i didn't get my green
card up
while i was at texas magic ended up
eventually joining google
um moving to the west coast and to
palo alto and i've been here ever since
now it's been 10 years
and you worked on fiber at google you
worked on their fiber project that was
one of this was the first thing i worked
on and so then actually matt
minnie ingersoll who is my co-founder at
shift
on that project she was my boss and then
uh we we
said it shifted was larry driving that
project or sergey i know one of the two
was obsessive about it
i think both actually both of them were
obsessing about it by the time i got to
google
the project was really far along so the
whole you know
towns applying or cities applying to be
part of the test had already happened
we're actually just kind of
working on city selection and what the
product would be in actuality because
um you know that was really critical but
i joined
let's say late into the project already
happening they were thinking very i
remember talking to either i can't
remember as lara sergey but
like during that time period had talked
to one of them about it
and they were like yeah jay where jake
how we're we're
literally figuring out how to use
hardcore equipment to rip
up parking lots to put fiber in and
figuring out how to do and i was like
what and they're like is this thing
first principles elon talks about
and i was like okay explain and they're
like yeah you know like the first
principles we have to be able to get
fiber
underground so we're we're literally in
the backyard of
cougar and he was telling me at google
he had one of those machines that rips
up the earth
yeah yeah and like either sergey or
larry was like driving the machine
trying to figure out how it worked
to rip up the air this is a true story
correct no it's 100 true and
i think the goal was to try to force the
traditional telecom providers
um to have faster internet rain and
that's actually happened so
you can look at google fibers oh like
did it fully succeed it didn't
in some people's eyes didn't get there
but from the perspective of what really
mattered which was to have
better internet for consumers broadly
very much actually happened ah and i had
written about that at a time in a way it
was like a short
a shot across the bow to the telecom
companies if you're not going to
increase
the speed of cable modems dsl well we
have unlimited capital and we have a
money printing machine at google
maybe we'll start just we'll pick a
couple towns and maybe a couple towns
becomes a couple cities
and let's see what happens and it did
push people to go faster
that's exactly